[Music]
uh first of all i don't know your dog's
name and i need to know this is blue
yeah blue just wanted to sit in on this
one if that's cool
listen i love animals so this is
actually i i'll be honest with you i
could interview if blue could talk um i
would push you out of the frame and just
talk the blue
he's kind of low maintenance as well he
just
he's just picking up anything that's
going on
see my question
my question is how come blue is blue in
venom uh two or and how come blue did
not get a role
blue's kind of behind the scenes you
know yeah he's like he he operates
behind the camera mainly
and
occasionally good venom reference
oh so jumping into why i actually get to
talk to you guys you guys both know um
i'm big fans of both of your work um so
thank you for giving me your time um tom
this is your first time getting a
writing credit on a movie i believe and
what is actually does that mean to you
um it just means that uh
i'm not really sure as much uh i think
it's just established that like i i'm
part of the family of of just in the
collaboration of of being in invested
within
um
being responsible to tell a story you
know for um
so it's not far from what i do anyway as
an actor um
i'm just invested in you know having
done the first one that we care you know
cared to to pitch for the second one uh
as soon as we we found out that they
wanted to do another one but really
kelly and i really wanted to have a shot
at creating a sandbox so that we could
work inside of that and and build on the
on the work and what we'd learned from
the first
film and and roll that back in uh
and work with the studio to to push
forward in a in you know in script form
so it's just making up stories really
and problem solving
not dissimilar to what i was doing on
taboo and stuff that i do anyway as an
actor now um
i just i guess i gotta i guess somebody
said yeah yeah you give me a bit of a
credit for it but there's not much of a
change to
for me yeah by the way i'm still waiting
on taboo season two but anyway um
um one of the things i was curious for
both of you guys i love learning the
behind the scenes of the making of a
movie um if you guys i'm i was just
thinking about one sequence that we
could talk about that you could sort of
maybe talk about the breaking down of it
of how you filmed it which and i figured
um the apartment fight scene just
towards the beginning of the film if you
could each maybe talk a little bit about
filming that sequence and maybe talk
about what fans would be surprised to
learn about making something like that
uh it's in two parts i think largely it
starts in a bathroom of
a mirror uh to a towel
in an argument which is internal
dialogue between uh eddie and venom uh
which then takes us up to a sink where
we have a chicken and drinking water
argument that then turns around all in
one shot to a reverse of the apartment
uh where venom appears by the couch and
then they become they have a tetat
moment where they discuss openly uh
they have a they haven't have at you
argument it's a verbal a kitchen sink
drama if you like
a look back in anger kind of one room uh
two-hander that then evolves into a
physical altercation at a pivot point on
the sofa on the couch
which uh because he's head-butted by by
venom at this point it becomes a
physical fight
and we decided we wanted to destroy the
apartment and we obviously have to split
the two people up
so this was our look back in anger
kitchen sink drama with you know buster
keaton elements to it as well um which
included live stunts cgi uh and some
some good old-fashioned face pulling
acting you know you know
amongst the three like for a basic
overview um technically
um how that would break down would be it
amongst those elements you do
not mean the acting bit is is kind of
earpiece talking to myself with the
sound underneath firing in across my
lines so that we can create the
interaction and i think that's one shot
isn't it the first yeah yeah yeah it's
just one shot very first thing we shot
in the movie yeah yeah so that's kind of
home territory that's quite quite a nice
comfortable mornings work for us you
know i mean it's it's easily contained
it then becomes more complicated when we
start throwing people through fridges um
up and and through bookshelves
we remove
things from the ceiling we punch holes
in things then
and and windows get smashed and
motorbikes and all kinds of things that
happen with elements and chickens get
thrown about which aren't real chickens
and we have to switch things out for
for props uh non-props that's uh that's
why i work there's wirework there's
green screen tongues
because at one point i'm pulling put in
venom's tongue uh it's not there so i'm
holding a phone green bat but largely
it's about one man in the room shaking
himself around pretending that there's
another creature there and another man
on wires who's jacob to murray
being thrown into um
furniture and then
it has to be choreographed in such a way
that um
that we can see the beast or the
symbiote or the the tentacles and the
the you know the papers flying out or
either they're live props or that then
they're not
yeah so over to you and what else
i think you covered i mean the great the
you know the important thing is to trick
the eye in a multitude of different ways
so it's like mixing it up mixing up the
physical reel with the with cg is always
you know it's always a happy blend
because you're not dependent you know
you could do you could do it all
yeah all in a cg way apart from wire
work in a green screen you know but we
wanted to literally physically smash
that place up didn't we and that and
that
you know you can really feel that
happening you wanted to feel that we
still have an argument within the drama
do you think so you're having a fight
you haven't but it's still a level of
tonality which is comic to it's
slapstick it but it's it's emotional
there's a there's a there's a an odd
couple argument between a married couple
who are having a domestic you know so
that the people on the street here these
people arguing like you know be quiet up
there and then they're having to talk
out the window so you're trying to do a
little fast uh like a french far stage
playing
in a small room you know it's quite it's
good fun you know it it's a good it's a
good
problem to have you know
and it breaks down into multiple
departments really that to to make that
happen you know i had knee surgeries as
well that was that was good fun remember
i'd had a knee surgery i had two knee
surgeries
yeah this man literally eight weeks
before had both knees operated on and
and he still went through all of that
just turning around in a pair of
slippers this is
very fragile so you know like uh
it was a really interesting and good fun
uh that and the they say the breakfast
scene you know where you're dealing with
uh
stuff that isn't there and is there like
the food is there but the fridge door
has been opened and closed with a wire
and your your chair has been pulled in
by a rope or whatever it is you know but
creating a a fantasy world and making it
come to life but in a in a sort of small
slightly sesame street way it's quite
quite good fun it's quite playful
in aspect